LAURA LING: The average
American produces
4.3 pounds of trash a day.
That's almost 1600
pounds a year,
but if we took
some simple steps,
we could go off the
trash grid and minimize
thousands of pounds of waste
into just a single jar.
LAUREN SINGER: So
this is my trash jar.
LAURA LING: Two years of
trash in this tiny little jar.
LAUREN SINGER: Yep.
LAURA LING: That's crazy.
I probably produce 20
times this much in a day.
LAUREN SINGER: Yeah, this
is everything basically
that I couldn't compost, or
couldn't recycle, or couldn't
figure out what to do with.
LAURA LING: Where did you get
this idea to become zero waste.
LAUREN SINGER: It
kind of all started
when I was a senior at NYU
studying environmental studies.
And one day after class, I
went home to make dinner,
and I open my fridge, and I
saw that everything in there
was packaged in plastic.
And I felt like
such a hypocrite.
We're supposed to be
saving the planet,
and here you are making
all of this trash.
I feel like it's really
important to live your values,
and my values are
having a really low
environmental impact.
I have to live like I want
that, and so that's why I
decided to change my lifestyle.
LAURA LING: What was the easiest
part about reducing your waste?
LAUREN SINGER: I
think it was just
seeing that I didn't have
to do that much to produce
very little waste, and by
composting and buying in bulk,
I essentially eliminated
80% of my waste.
Buying package
free means needing
to have containers to
buy things that you
can't hold with your hands.
For instance, I
buy bulk olive oil,
so I bring a mason
jar to fill it up.
I'll pick up some beer from
a local shop that sells it
in growlers that are
actually reusable,
so that's a totally
waste free way to drink.
LAURA LING: I imagine you
get asked a lot of questions
about how do you do this.
I've been curious
about a few things.
I'm going to throw out
a few questions too.
Plastic toothbrushes?
LAUREN SINGER: I use a
compostable bamboo toothbrush.
LAURA LING: Sponges?
LAUREN SINGER: I use a
compostable dish brush.
LAURA LING: Paper towels?
LAUREN SINGER: Cotton napkins.
LAURA LING: Plastic cookware?
LAUREN SINGER: Wood or
stainless steel utensils?
LAURA LING: Cotton balls?
LAUREN SINGER:
Reusable cotton rounds.
LAURA LING: Dryer sheets?
LAUREN SINGER: Dryer
balls that I make myself.
LAURA LING: What about shampoo?
LAUREN SINGER:
Bulk castile soap.
LAURA LING: Makeup?
LAUREN SINGER: Organic vegan
makeup in recyclable packaging.
LAURA LING: Feminine products?
LAUREN SINGER: Menstrual cup.
LAURA LING: Gift wrap?
LAUREN SINGER: Why?
LAURA LING: OK, so you
are going to teach me
how to make toothpaste.
LAUREN SINGER: Yes.
LAURA LING: What do I do?
LAUREN SINGER: So
we're going to mix
two tablespoons of
organic coconut oil,
and then a tablespoon
of baking soda, and then
about 20 drops of the
organic peppermint oil.
LAURA LING: So this is how
you make your toothpaste.
LAUREN SINGER: Mm-hm.
LAURA LING: Let
me see your teeth.
[LAUGHTER]
They look very nice.
LAUREN SINGER: Yeah.
LAURA LING: What does your
dentist think about this?
LAUREN SINGER: They haven't
gotten mad at me yet.
So I'll just take this spoon
and scoop it onto my toothbrush.
LAURA LING: It's not bad.
It's actually kind of salty.
LAUREN SINGER: Yeah,
that's the baking soda.
LAURA LING: Yeah, my teeth
really do feel cleaner.
So, thank you.
So do you have any garbage
cans in your home here?
LAUREN SINGER: No, I don't have
any garbage cans in my home.
LAURA LING: Because you
don't have any garbage.
LAUREN SINGER: Exactly.
LAURA LING: It
really does compel
me to want to try
to reduce my waste.
So what tips can you
give me or somebody else
that wants to do that as well?
LAUREN SINGER: I would suggest
look in your garbage can
and see what your
garbage is, and until you
do that, you don't really
know what you're reducing.
Step two, using a reusable bags
instead of a plastic or paper
bag.
Just easy one time changes.
And then the last one
would be to actually
make your products yourself.
So learn how to make toothpaste.
Learn how to make deodorant.
It's a really fun thing to do.
LAURA LING: What is
your ultimate goal?
LAUREN SINGER: Before
I lived my lifestyle,
I wonder why is there all
this trash and why is that OK?
We have to find solutions
before it gets out of control.
I've never told anyone, oh,
you should live this lifestyle
or you have to live this way.
I kind of just
live my lifestyle,
put it out there,
and see what happens.
LAURA LING: Be sure to check
out another episode of "Going
Off Grid" with Mike Basich and
his 225 square foot tiny home.
MIKE BASICH: I like to
think of it as getting back
to the basics of humanity.
I like feeling
connected to the earth.
LAURA LING: This episode is
a part of seeker stories.
We're trying to bring you cool
stories from around the world,
but in order to do that,
you need to subscribe.
So please click on that button,
and thanks for watching.